foreign
[Music]
it's Monday June 12th I'm Zoe Thomas for
The Wall Street Journal
passwords are getting longer require
more special characters and it seems
like every website and app these days
needs one
but if you think it's a pain to create
one password imagine how frustrating it
would be to find out your login
credentials for multiple maybe even
dozens of sites were stolen and are
being sold on the dark web with me to
discuss how to deal with this situation
is our personal Tech reporter Dalvin
Brown Dalvin a lot of people find
themselves in this predicament what
should they do the problem is that
people reuse their passwords quite often
and it's understandable I mean we have
more online services every year and so
then once one password gets compromised
well that could be the password to
multiple services and so hackers could
get into any number of things by just
finding out one password so you can come
up with a plan of action and I spoke
with some cyber security folks who said
that all passwords aren't created equal
and all sites that those passwords are
used on aren't created equally either so
there are some sites that you don't have
to be as quick to to change the password
on if it's just some website where you
go and browse content but you're not
messaging anyone then those may not have
to be changed at all but you want to
prioritize anything that's linked to
your bank so any apps or websites that
have access to your banking information
your address or your contacts those are
places that you want to change the
password and create a unique password
for them and also turn on two-factor
authentication when you can after that
you want to think about your Social
Circle anywhere where someone can
overtake your account pretend that
they're you and drain money from people
you know so I think like social media
are there any sites or apps that might
help in these situations yes so a lot of
the places where you would store your
passwords can also tell you if those
passwords have been compromised so
iCloud keychain for all of Apple's
devices can offer security
recommendations if you go in your
settings and you'll be able to see all
of the passwords that have been
compromised or that are high risk
meaning they're probably easy to be
guessed on Chrome there's also a lookup
tool to find your week reused or like
compromised passwords Microsoft Edge and
then if you use a password manager like
Dashlane or one password they both
constantly scan the internet and the
dark web for your credentials any of
your saved credentials and if they
realize that hey that your email address
or password that you have saved in your
password manager is showing up on the
dark web they'll alert you and like give
you tips on how to change it you know
we're talking about
for different size it's what if you've
used just different variations of the
same password for multiple sites will
you also be at risk yeah so you want
your passwords to be totally unique what
cyber Security Experts told me is that
accuracy that your password is one two
three four saved on the dark web some
will just try one two three four five
and see if it lets them into an account
so you want to make sure that they're
totally unique and that's where password
managers can step in and help by
generating long unique passwords but
again it's a catch-22 because if you're
ever using a device where you don't have
access to your password manager
immediately you know it may be hard to
get into some of those accounts
words they need to
need many of them is there a way of
preventing this from happening from
preventing your passwords from being
stolen no oh there's no way to totally
prevent your password from being
compromised if it's saved somewhere it
can show up somewhere there are even
examples where password managers have
been hacked and compromised but experts
tell me it's more worrisome to know that
your password is compromised and do
nothing you're at a higher risk of
getting hacked or having your accounts
accessed by someone other than yourself
if you don't change them and so paying
attention to these alerts like they they
matter however you can't prevent your
password from being hacked
forever there's just some things you can
do to address the issue once it happens
so don't bury your head in the sand if
you find out you have a password that's
been hacked
a personal Tech reporter Dalvin Brown
and that's it for today's Tech news
briefing for more Tech stories head over
to our website
wsj.com I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall
Street Journal thanks for listening
foreign